en un momento de tensión y descontento
nacional Pedro Castillo encabezó el
desfile militar que conmemora el 200 un
aniversario de la independencia de Perú
El mandatario cuenta con cinco
investigaciones abiertas en su contra
por presuntos delitos de corrupción algo
que se ha vuelto común en Perú en los
últimos 30 años seis presidentes Dentro
de este periodo de tiempo tienen
problemas con la justicia Martín
vizcarra afronta investigación bajo
mandato de comparecencia y con
restricciones de conducta por presunto
delito de colusión agravada y otros
casos su predecesor Pedro Pablo
kuczynski cumple arresto domiciliario
por lavado de activos ollanta humala se
enfrenta un proceso penal por presuntos
delitos de lavado de activos y
asociación ilícita para delinquir pasó
nueve meses en prisión preventiva las
mismas acusaciones pesaban contra Alan
García que se suicidó mientras la
policía lo esperaba afuera de su
vivienda para restarlo por su parte
Alejandro prófugo en Estados Unidos
cuenta con dos órdenes de prisión
preventiva y un pedido de extradición la
Fiscalía de Perú lo acusa de haber
recibido 20 millones de dólares de la
empresa brasileña odebrecht finalmente
Alberto fujimori cumple una condena de
25 años en prisión por crímenes contra
los derechos humanos y asociación
ilícita al parecer la otra pandemia en
Perú es la corrupción entre los altos
cargos del gobierno